paris va vous ai déjà fait pas mal de
choses dans votre vie on va voir ce qui
est fait et ce qui reste à faire
on va faire une interview fait ou à
faire vous présenter dans un concours de
beauté effet ou à faire faire la bise à
jean pierre foucault fait ou affaires
fed et dès la première heure de faire de
la figuration dans un épisode de julie
lescaut fait ou à faire inauguré un
salon de l'agriculture fait ou affaires
à faire peut-être serait peut-être bien
de le faire
ça serait bien ça ferait plaisir à jean
de vienne voilà nous regardent vous
savez je regardais la balle et là je la
vois je te vois tu sais je le vis à vis
tu cette île elle râle en plus vrai
quand même pas quand tu parle d'aller à
l'apa son chapeau la dentelle et devant
la télé chez elle la voit aussi
oui je sais pas mais la regarde la croix
la poubelle sujet
elle est en train de manger sa boîte de
thon combien de temps pour faire ce
disque m'a rien d'aisance deux ans
pourquoi pourquoi deux en deux ans parce
que entre entre l'idée entre le temps
j'ai bien
landes quand j'ai commencé à
m'intéresser aux années 60
je connaissais vraiment pas grand chose
à part un mythe bardot françoise hardy
et il a fallu que je me documente que je
passe des heures à la fnac regarder des
dvd à lire des livres à écouter vraiment
plein plein de choses et si même des
arts là bas
et ça prend du temps tout simplement et
je suis arrivé avec deux ans quand deux
ans
et je suis arrivé avec une liste de 35
chansons je voulais reprendre beaucoup
plus de choses n'étaient pas possibles
donc il fallait faire un choix et puis
il fallait concevoir les musiques et
voix là et j'ai rien laisser au hasard
sur cet album jusqu'au choix des des
photographes du réalisateur du clip et
ça prend du temps
pourquoi deux ans quand même beaucoup
d'aisance toyas dominique va poser une
question tel permis si je pense à un
boulot avant vas-y continuent de surfer
les voir ouais non mais un autre truc tu
sais on pourra les voir c'est sympa
c'est bien parce que même si on fait une
chanson par mois ça fait 12 ans 12 mois
d'août un nom je sais j'étais juste
comme j'étais pas chanteuse fallait que
je travaille un peu à quoi se sent pas
du tout et que tu vas pas penser à lundi
sur les années 70 c'est un nom
possibilité pour l'un 80 90
mais j'ai petit cadeau faut choisir
c'est parce que ça me ressemblait pas ce
que ça me parlait que et que les femmes
étaient des icônes dans ces années là et
on a compris pourquoi les années 60 e
ressemblait plus que les années 50
tu verras pour toi sa démission
on reçoit un garçon s'appelle fabrice
gaignault qui écrit un livre sur
l'échiquier chéri sixties et tu verras
tu comprendras à ce moment là bas
d'accord attend pas d'accord à attendre
voilà les noms je trouve que pour les
jeunes de ma génération et la générosité
mais je sais qu'ils font n'a pas de 14 à
27 ans j'ai 27 ans je trouve qu'on n'a
pas on n'a pas d'icône aujourd'hui et on
n'a personne en tout cas pour moi je
m'identifie à ségolène quand même
ségolène smith et hills et mcc gueule
c'est pas les années 60 elle présentait
une émission télé en petit je fais aux
affaires
qu'est ce que tu veux faire non
j'aimerais pas vouloir devenir
comédienne sait où affaire fait affaire
parce que je suis pas non plus une
comédienne qui a fait 50 mille trucs je
n'ai jamais fait sérieusement je faisais
jamais de casting voilà je préférais
partir en week-end en angleterre c'est
mal à écrire un livre qui raconte
l'odyssée ou affaire s'est pas fait en
tout cas mais c'est vrai que j'ai appris
beaucoup
j'écris beaucoup bien poser nue dans un
magazine pour hommes faits ou à faire
pas encore fait je sais pas si je le
veux peut-être que je le ferai avec un
staff comme peter lindbergh peut-être
dans un contexte années 60 un pabx ou
quelques d'aujourd'hui un truc un peu un
concept un truc un peu concède tiennent
les boys de l'époque voilà trouver un
pygmalion fait aux affaires non c'est
pas fait c'est à dire j'imagine que vous
pensez à jean-charles en disant ça mais
c'est pas mon pygmalion c'est bien on
est on est complet on est
complémentaires et c'est quelqu'un qui
m'a toujours soutenu dans mes choix et
qui me répète je l' ai connu avec donc
il ya sept ans et il m'a toujours
conforté dans mes choix et dans mes
décisions en me répétant une phrase de
rené char qui disait va vers ton risque
à te regarder il dit des trucs comme ça
non mais oui mais en faire très
attention ce que c'était une phrase
employée bout de course jean marie
messier
jean marie messier se regarde à te
regarder ils s'habitueront parce que
j'étais différente et que parfois on me
disait mais écoute tu peux pas faire des
choses comme ça s'est passé comme après
tout la boue les bains va vers ton
risque à te regarder ils s'habitueront
c'est assez simple et
et c'était ça parce que j'étais m voilà
quand je tarifs des pertes est perdu est
souvent te dis il faut pas faire ça tu
devrais faire ça ou c'est une
catastrophe pour ta carrière
mon cher on va peut-être genève est
temps que je voulais et quand je voulais
faire des choses qui n'étaient pas dans
un heads d'archétypes dans un archétype
d'une miss france ou voilà il me dit il
me confortait dans mais dans mes choix
et dans mes décisions et que son
deuxième prénom et duracell donc elle
est très je suis à fond chef changer
régulièrement dame en fait aux affaires
non non non moi je te reconnais 3
révélait un drame sur sa vie privée
frais ou à faire c'est pas fâché pas si
j'ai besoin de le faire non jeu viendra
bientôt les couleurs qui a mal tourné
les rosiers au but comme ça s'appelle
sais pas c'est pas glorieux on aurait pu
s'arrêter un drame
c'est un drame dans ta vie non tu aurais
pas par mais pas la france a été
traumatisée tu étais un truc qui
pourrait faire un bouquin non non mitigé
sur la plage en jour en fin de journée
un peu gâchée inauguré un supermarché
fait ou à faire je n'ai jamais fait je
suis pas sûr que j'aimerais le faire
sané - quel rayon sait toujours pas
[Musique]
je pense pas catherine que ça soit une
très bonne idée d'avoir mis laurent
baffie et d'armand à clés publiques oak
est un gros déconneur point qu'on le
fouille à en sortir
attention evelyne thomas vous le dites
fait ou pas fait je suis rousse est
alors fait je suis fou amoureux de mon
chien s'est pas fait oh c'était pas
intitulé comme ça mais bon
mais me fais ce que j'aime bien ça
j'aurais passé le vide pour moi aussi
dit chad vous verrez les gens vont vous
embrasser et où il aurait des pluie de
pétales de roses attention je me moque
de mon hygiène l'habite de mon mari a un
goût déjà fait je fais des choses que
personne ne fait avec la [ __ ] de mon
mari qui est un ami je fais des choses
que personne ne fait feu c'est pas très
précis mais j'ai dit c'est ouais ça
devait pas est intitulé comme ça je fais
peur aux gens je cultive ma ressemblance
avec une star ces critiques mais je
cultive sa ressemblance
je cultive ma ressemblance avec moi même
non pas tant les noms je communique avec
l'au delà
je communique avec l'au delà mais c'est
lui qui paye je suis fakir n'ont pas
fait j'arrive à moto sucer
[Musique]
joue avec jim morrison fait ou à faire
affaire à faire jouer de la musique à
poil sur scène fait ou affaires à faire
tomber amoureuse de tommy lee jones
ça s'est déjà fait traverser les usa en
van volkswagen
cette affaire j'étais à l'arrière d'une
voiture mais je dépuceler un fan fait ou
à faire oublier les paroles sur scène
c'est ou à faire c'est un mérite à ses
banques
seulement couché avec votre meilleur ami
e fait ou à faire
qu'est-ce qui a déjà duré je dis bon
courage
alors vous répondez fait ou à faire une
nuit avec de geisha à faire avant un
débat philosophique avec jean claude van
damme a fait un scrabble avec joey starr
a fait une piqûre avant un combat
enfin fait ouais c'est a fait fait
figure de joker j'avais mal à un genou
mamadou kane question va vérifier un la
faire sauter la licence ou en chu zen
une chaussette dans votre short pour
impressionner les fans à faire vous
faire casser la gueule par un mec d'un
mètre soixante déjà fait déjà fait
je tombe à pic à l'écossé comme ça cette
affiche les français nous servons les
couilles eu cure acceptez de vous
coucher pour de l'argent robert rappelle
toi n'ont cependant pas moins une menace
pas jeter l'épongé en plein combat
sinon les proches la nature le drame on
va faire encore approché mais y'a plein
de trucs que vous avez à faire alors ça
je vois mes membres cassés ont été jetés
par les tronches de ça les gars tiff pas
- ou le lol faut pas l'emmerder non mais
jérôme faut pas l'emmerder sa
séquestration
tu dis fait ou pas fait avoir le crâne
rasé fait se battre avec des fans a pas
fait porter des pantalons trop petit au
fait sauter dans le public fait se
mettre torse nu sur scène fait est trop
saoul pour jouer correctement sur ça
fait monter sur scène des français fait
montrer son cul sur scène
en général quand ça m'arrive je vous ai
je suis dans un état où je me rappelle
pas ce que je fais pis en scène c'était
arrivé toi c'était arrivé toit ont pissé
contre un ampli non je crois pas j'ai un
minimum de respect pour le public pour
les surplus et pour les amplis se
retrouver dans le lit d'une inconnue
fait richard tu peux jouer aussi un jeu
c'est pas bien de réponse se retrouver
au lit avec deux inconnues non il ya
très longtemps oui ça m'est arrivé de me
retrouver au elle lit avec deux mais pas
des inconnus faire une conférence de
presse à poil dans une chambre d'hôtel
fait ou affaires à faire casser sa
chambre d'hôtel
tu l'as fait frais il a fait non gueuler
contre la guerre toi tu l'as fait dream
je vais arrive pour moi oui se faire
arrêter dans un aéroport pour détention
de cannabis dans une frontière mais pas
de cannabis tu m'inquiètes la décharge
un détention de cannabis à la frontière
à ces cons parce qu'ils y étaient pas
d'habitude et puis cette fois ci avoir
plus d'alcool que de sang dans le corps
neuf sur mon fait oui brûle un billet de
banque pour allumé un cigare non j'suis
pas le sig a couché avec sa cousine de
présents c'est jerry lee lewis est un
site non genre est cousine s'est habillé
tout en cuir même le string banon hurler
gloire à satan sur cette île pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de 1h10 tube
abonnez vous mettez un pouce bleus